Narrator:
A METALWORKER CLAMPS THE DISK
AGAINST A FORM IN A LATHE.
AS THE LATHE SPINS,
HE PRESSES THE DISK TO THE FORM
USING A BLUNT TOOL.
THIS TRANSFORMS THE DISK
INTO A FLARED VESSEL,
ONE THAT LOOKS LIKE
A FLOWER POT.
A CUTTER AT THE SIDE
TRIMS THE RIM.
THEY CALL THIS FLOWER-POT SHAPE
THE DRAFT.
A WORKER PRESSES THE SPINNING
DRAFT TO ANOTHER FORM.
THIS STRETCHES THE ALUMINUM
SHAPE LONGER AND NARROWER.
FINALLY, THEY TAPER THE CYLINDER
AT THE TOP
TO FORM A SLANTED CHIMNEY
AND SLICE OFF THE BOTTOM.
HE DRILLS A HOLE
IN THE GRADIENT OF THE KETTLE.
HE INSERTS A SCREW
THAT'S ATTACHED TO A PUNCH.
THEN, USING AN ALLEN WRENCH,
HE TURNS THE SCREW,
FORCING THE PUNCH INTO THE METAL
TO CUT OUT A HOLE
FOR THE KETTLE SPOUT.
HE NOW SLIDES THE KETTLE BODY
OVER A POST
WITH A DIE THAT FITS
INTO THE SPOUT HOLE.
HE PLACES THE SPOUT OVER THE DIE
AND HAMMERS IT INTO THE HOLE.
NEXT, THE INNER WALL OF
THE GHILLIE KETTLE TAKES SHAPE.
WIELDING A TOOL WITH FORCE,
A WORKER PULLS AND STRETCHES
THE ALUMINUM DISK
INTO A LONG CONE.
HE INSERTS THE CONE
IN THE KETTLE BODY.
A GAP BETWEEN THEM WILL SERVE
AS THE WATER CHAMBER,
AND SMOKE WILL BE
VENTED OUT THE CENTER.
HE ROLLS
THE UPPER LIP OF THE CONE
AROUND THE KETTLE'S TOP RIM,
LOCKING THEM TOGETHER.
HE ALSO SECURES THEM
AT THE BASE THE SAME WAY.
HE TRANSFERS THE GHILLIE KETTLE
TO A STAND
TO KEEP IT UPRIGHT
AS HE RIVETS STEEL EARS TO IT.
THE EARS ARE FOR ATTACHING
THE HANDLE AND A CHAIN
FOR THE KETTLE WHISTLE.
THE BASE OF THE GHILLIE KETTLE
IS THIS FIRE CHAMBER.
FOR PACKING PURPOSES,
HE STACKS IT UPSIDE DOWN
AND PLACES THE KETTLE OVER IT.
HE WRAPS THE ENTIRE KETTLE
IN BRITISH NEWSPRINT
FOR SHIPPING.
THIS PROTECTS IT
AND ALSO GIVES THE PURCHASER
SOMETHING TO BURN
THE FIRST TIME
HE OR SHE TRIES IT OUT.
HE CRIMPS THE ENDS
OF THE HANDLE
TO THE EARS THAT PROTRUDE
THROUGH THE HEADLINES.
HE PLACES THE WHISTLE
OVER THE WRAPPED SPOUT
AND THEN TUCKS THE KETTLE
INTO A DRAWSTRING TOTE.